[Music]
you are on fire superstar Courtney
hadwin brought down the house and during
the first night of America's Got Talent
Finals best of the best on the best
night on the best show on television the
14 year old singer performed a powerful
rendition of Tina Turner's classic River
deep Mountain High on Tuesday night
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
which got simon cowell melb Heidi Klum
and Howie Mandel on their feet I always
say the most important part of being a
star is being remembered and that's what
you do every time you perform people are
gonna remember you you're gonna inspire
people you can't you're gonna tell a
whole new generation of people what rock
and roll is all about et caught up with
the singer backstage after the show this
was a big performance for you tonight
obviously that it's finale week how
would you describe how you're feeling in
one word proud have you given any
thought to how you would spend that
million dollars if you were lucky enough
to win tomorrow night I'm not really
sure if I'm gonna win tomorrow night
everybody's amazing and unique in their
own way
win or lose something major is gonna
happen to you what's next what do you
hope is next after this year I really
want to be able to release my own music
and show people my own music and
hopefully be able
do conflict some live shows maybe at the
Greek theater I mean are you gonna miss
LA in Hollywood I wanted a fan really
yeah you're like that now that I've
visited all these iconic locations where
a lot of your icons started you're like
I want to be here too you think your
family would be willing to make the move
with you
[Music]